so we have jc outside did you see i saw
i saw that and i literally
ran by jc i know and it was spooky
looking halloween of course
uh is the iconic horror movie you've
seen that right
and today las vegas is celebrating one
of the men behind
the mask jc fernandez is joining us live
outside the station with more hey jc
hey guys look it is mike myers mike
myers from halloween how are you
he's a he's a man he's a man of few
words okay mcmahon he's this scary
mantra you can step back just a second
there and i want to bring in
the man of the hour actually this is
james winburn who was the stuntman in
the very first mike my very first
halloween movie how are you james
i'm doing great so how does a stuntman
land a role
in the movie halloween i got the job to
deborah hill
i was working on police story and she
called me to my answering service
and asked me if i would peer in north
into hollywood
on orange grove avenue and i said i'll
try
but i'll have to ask the production
people if i can get off
and fortunately they let me go and then
he went over there and i met john for
the first time that's john carpenter the
man behind the movie so
i want to talk about the iconic scene of
yours uh the final scene we're showing
it right now where
where mike myers gets shot he falls down
we think we think he's dead
how many takes to do that scene one one
take
one taken done right here that's how jim
does it and then my last question for
you i heard a rumor is it true
that you never saw the movie start to
finish i have never seen the full movie
that isn't
we'll watch it when we're done we'll
watch it tonight together
well uh i only see bits and pieces we'll
make sure you see it at some point
thank you so much for being honored
tonight and this is paul casey
the man behind everything so tonight how
are we how are we honoring jim
well today we're honoring with the city
of las vegas an official proclamation
from councilman brian knutson ward one
at the mirabella park at six o'clock
tonight so mike myers is officially
getting his own day here in las vegas he
is is actually going to be designated
for october 31st how appropriate
and it's pretty exciting to be a part of
this history and austin you bring a lot
of events to town and we have
an old school hearst behind us what's
the story behind this car where's it
gonna be well this will be at the event
tonight this 1969 uh
hurst uh cadillac hurst superior and
it's owned by the
lombardos they're here today sandy and
pat and they're gonna be there tonight
and
we're pretty excited they're going to be
a part of this as well and it's a
saturday night it's going to be a trunk
or treat halloween event down at
atomic liquor so people can come down
that's currently spooky cars
and jim's big night thank you for
joining us today jim i appreciate it
a true hollywood legend thank you jc
happy halloween everyone all right let's
send it back to you guys
in the studio is it scary mike myers has
that mask on
that is amazing too that he has never
watched the movie oh and he's probably
like i don't want to watch it
right that's incredible been there done
that we